Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie a bunch of you
guys last night requested a Superman black
costume video just because people think that
they may have seen another look from behind
the scenes Warner Bros. typically doesn't
comment on stuff like this and it may be fake.
It looks like a very convincing fake if it
is, but I wanted to explain the black costume
from the comics because there's a long history
of him wearing it and all the Justice league
prequel scenes that set up his return because
even just in the couple of movies that we've
seen so far, we've seen him come back to life.
So there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so this
is really cool, but a lot of people think
that this is fake.
So just a pending official confirmation we
just had to take it both ways, but the reason
why people think that he's wearing a black
suit at some point in the movie is because
he was buried in his black kryptonian suit
in the comics the original suit as you can
see was just torn to shreds in his fight with
doomsday the same thing happened after Superman's
fight with doomsday and Batman view Superman
and if you remember all of the kryptonian's
wear black under Armour like that's their
version of underwear that they walk around
and it Superman's costume was colored blue
to look like that there's actually a lot of
black kryptonian suits that are left on earth
after all this kryptonian stuff in the man
of steel movie and aesthetically they been
pretty true to the comics all explained the
black suit from the comics as well as the
return of Superman in the movies.
They've already given us all the evidence
that we need and the synopsis for Justice
league that tease out some of the mother box
threat from Darkside.
They basically act like beacons that alert
Darkseid's minions and Steppenwolf to what's
going on on earth so that sort of tease up
the events of Justice league which obviously
gives Batman the nightmares that we saw during
Batman view Superman.
So will get like a couple really key scenes
as well as the comic book black suit stuff,
so far the only confirmed new hard-core suit
that we've seen is from Batman just because
of this increased threat.
Even the Batmobile gets juiced up to five
parody men's the actual synopsis tells you
a little bit about how crazy the threat is
going to be so that explains why some of the
worry more hard-core suits, but it says fueled
by his restored faith in humanity and inspired
by Superman's selfless act.
Bruce Wayne enlists the help of his newfound
ally Diana Prince to face an even greater
enemy together Batman and wonder woman were
quickly to find and recruit a team of metahuman's
which we also here to stand against the newly
awakened threat which makes you think about
the mother boxes alerting them to their presence
on earth but despite the formation of this
unprecedented league of heroes using very
special language there Batman wonder woman
Aquaman cyborg in the flash it may already
be too late to save the planet from an assault
of catastrophic proportions.
So you basically have that man's nightmare
slowly coming true, albeit in a slightly different
way.
So this is that Batman view Superman scene
where the parody men's rush him so.
Just imagine a version of this without the
Superman symbolism here
now what is that synopsis tell you.
It tells you that Superman is not around like
he is in any of the promo material even though
he was in the behind-the-scenes teaser that
they released a while ago there filming the
movie wearing his blue costume hard-core,
comic book fans will notice that he does not
have a mullet in this picture.
So either he's gotten a haircut or there will
be no mullet the reason for the mullet in
the comics is just because this was a 90s
thing that was a 90s hairstyle.
So Superman dies the eradicate or and steals
his body and starts bombarding him with solar
energy to try and bring him back overloads
it and blows up the system, but he returns,
but in that time span.
His hair has grown out so he just rolls with
the new haircut was meant to be sort of a
redesign for the character so just a tea this
up in the movies.
We've already seen a couple scenes that have
told us how he's coming back.
So I'm in a play like this last little scene,
so we'll talk about the return of Superman
and how that worked out in the comics is a
slightly different story where the black costume
comes from.
So the funny thing about that scene is really
just attended the tell you that Superman is
slowly coming back to life.
They had that scene where he got nuked earlier
in the film with his fight with doomsday where
the sun healed him.
That was all intended to sort of tea that
up to let you know hey sunlight makes him
better.
He could come back from a near death experience
or even death itself just as long as he gets
sunlight solar radiation from our yellow son
so buried in the coffin underneath the ground
he's getting very very little solar energy.
It just takes a long time for his body to
heal.
So the dust that's like slowly rising off
the coffin here doesn't totally makes sense
because Superman doesn't levitate things around
him.
He levitates himself but I think the explanation
here is that when he flies like this is getting
to hard-core technical explanation here when
he flies there just like a small field around
his body that allows him like a certain measure
of tactical nieces but it's not like he's
telekinetic Superman's have a lot of crazy
powers in the classic comics, but in the modern
continuity they tried to be a little more
simple about it.
The point is is that they just want to let
you know that Superman is coming back.
But is not can happen to the next movie in
a very ambiguous about the timing of when
he's coming back because kryptonian science
is still very new to the earth.
Nobody knows about this, so Batman thinks
he's dead.
Wonder woman thinks he's dead even though
she seen a lot of things she said she's killed
things that are not from this earth so it
was kind of surprised when she just bought
Superman's death.
Face value, but when you look at the suit
is way more hard-core than the black, comic
book suit which it it itself is also just
a standard kryptonian suit that he wears,
it's almost like kryptonian under Armour if
you remember from the man of steel movie,
the kind of tune the colors down so it's hard
to tell.
But they all wear suits like that underneath
there regular armor back during man of steel
when he found that first kryptonian ship gave
him the Superman costume the blue one that
he warned that first movie the ship itself
made the costume.
It just sort of like a made to order thing
based on Jarrell's specifications and Superman's
input.
So in the way that Lex tries to tap into the
kryptonian ship and learn things people can
use kryptonian technology.
But as of the beginning a Batman view Superman
there was like a prequel comic where you learn
that even Bruce Wayne's company has been studying
kryptonian technology.
So even if that ship was blown up and Superman
just can fabricate anything he wants anymore.
There's other ways to adapt kryptonian technology
to help him out, and I think that were headed
for eventual Fortress of solitude in the movies
but maybe not till the next man of steel movie
which will just tentatively call the man of
tomorrow you guys let me know if you agree
though do you feel like they're going to leave
Superman out of all the marketing materials
at least the early marketing materials for
Justice league that's gonna be ramping up
later this year but I feel like they still
want to have an element of surprise even though
the producers have acknowledged that he's
coming back everybody that's ever read a comic
book knows that he's coming back everybody
that saw the movie and stayed through the
end a Batman view Superman saw that he's coming
back.
So it's one of those weird situations where
all the fans are just kind of like sitting
there waiting for something to happen that
they know is going to happen just really hyped
up.
Congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner Christopher Murray these private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details what can happen later
tonight is I was gonna do a Green Lantern
video because there been talk about the casting,
there's a lot of funny stories behind that
Bradley Cooper audition for the original Green
Lantern and now is back on their list, so
is Ryan Reynolds, it's a big WTF, but because
of Marvel comics have been tanking lately,
everybody feels like there's going to be a
DC style rebirth for Marvel during infinity
war.
So I'll do a video for that tonight infinity
war Marvel rebirth and then Green Lantern
tomorrow along with new game of thrones while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my breakdown of the other Justice
league costumes they just showed off and you
can click here for the trailer for the next
episode of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!